ايران تتراجع وتسمح باستئناف التحقيق
بانشطتها النوويه وجروسي يؤكد اعاده
كاميرات المراقبه
روسيا تؤكد تعزيز التعاون العسكري مع
الصين ردا على تعزيزات الناتو في اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ
كوريا الشماليه تطالب بوقف فوري للتدريبات
العسكريه المشتركه بين امريكا وكوريا
الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر
البدايه من التطور اللافت في ملف ايران
نووي اذ كشفت وكاله ان تقريرا لبكاله
الطاقه الذريه افاد بان ايران قدم
الضمانات للقضاء العالقه بشان الملف
النووي واضافه بنقلا عن التقرير نفسه بان
طهران تراجعت وسمحت للوكاله باستئناف
التحقيق بانشطتها كما ستعمل على توضيح
تواجد جزيئات يورانيوم في منشاه فوردو
بدوره اكد جروسي انا كاميرات المراقبه
ستعود الى المنشات النوويه الايرانيه
اتفقنا على عدد من الاجراءات الملموسه
فخلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه كان هناك
انخفاض في بعض انشطه المراقبه لذا قررنا
مضاعفتها ووضع المزيد من الكاميرات وتعزيز
انظمه التدقيق عبر الانترنت واصلاح المعطل
منها المهم بالنسبه لنا هو ان ايران
ستلتزم بدرجه التحصيب المحدده لها في
منشاه فوردو وستحترم هذا الالتزام
اعلنا وزير الداخليه الايرانيه احمد وحيده
ان الاجهزه الامنيه تتابع قضيه تسمم
الطالبات في اكثر من خمسين مدرسه وثانويه
بالبلاد ادت الى نقل عدد كبير منهن الى
المستشفى اقل وحيدي ان محققين عثروا على
عينات مشبوهه مشيرا الى ان هناك تحقيقات
متخصصه تستهدف الوقوف على اسباب ما سماها
المضاعفات التي حدثت للطالبات واضاف وزير
الداخليه بان صحه الطالبات تمثله الاولويه
القصوى لجميع المسؤولين خصوصا بعد اتساع
نطاق الاحتجاجات بهذا الشان في اكثر من
مدينه لتشمل العاصمه طهران واصفهان
وكرمنشاه
موجه تسمم تجتاح مدارس الفتيات في ايران
تقارير اعلاميه ايرانيه افادت بالتعرض
طالبات للتسمم في اكثر من 50 مدرسه وثنويه
بمزيج من غازات سامه وارسال عدد كبير منهن
الى المستشفيات
الطالبات تسممنا عن طريق الاستنشاق
ويعانين من اعراض الغثيان والضعف والدوار
والسعال وضيق التنفس
قناه ايران انترناشونال افادت باتساع نطاق
الاحتجاجات على تسمم الطالبات في اكثر من
مدينه لتشمل العاصمه طهران واصفهان
وكرمنشاه واردبيل
حيث الطالبات تمثل الاولويه القصوى
والاجهزه الامنيه تتابع قضيه تسممين وقد
وثرت على عينه مشبوهه في عده مدارس في
البلاد هذا ما اعلنه وزير الداخليه
الايراني احمد وحيدي
ثلاثه اشهر مرت على سلسله عمليات التسمم
التي تعرضنا لها الطالبات ولم يتم التعرف
على منفذي الهجمات قوات الامن الايراني
اعتقلت عددا من الاسر التي تجمعت امام
مبنى وزاره التربيه والتعليم قبل ترحيل
بعضهم الى سجن ايفين
اجرى رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه الجنرال مارك ميلي زيارتها
مفاجئه لسوريا لتقييم مهمه عمرها ثمانيه
اعوام تقريبا لمحاربه الارهاب ومراجعه
اجراءات حمايه القوات الامريكيه من اي
هجوم وبحسب رويترز قال ميلي ان زيارته
لسوريا الضروريه وتستحق المخاطره واضاف
بان القوات الامريكيه وشركائها السوريين
الذين يقودهم الاكراد يحرزون تقدما في
ضمان الحاق هزيمه دائمه بالارهاب
اعلنا السفير الروسي لدى الصين ايغورا
مارجلوف بان موسكو وبيكينت تعززان التعاون
العسكريه التقني ردا على محاوله الناتو
الذي تعمل على تعزيز قدراتها في منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
قشار ايضا الى ان روسيا والصين ستواصلان
شرح المخاطر والتهديدات التي يمثلها وجود
النيتو في المنطقه لجميع دول اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ وستواصلان ايضا بناء التعاون
العسكري مع الدول الشركه للحفاظ على
الهيكل الامني للمنطقه
اوكرانيا حاله التاهب الجوي في مناطق
مختلفه للتصدي لهجوم الروسيه محتمل وبحسب
السلطات فان المناطق التي تشملها حاله
التاهب هي بلطافا
واجزاء من مقاطعه
ملموس لقوه فاغنر في عمق مدينه باخموت
التي تشهد اعتى المعارك واعنفها بين الجيش
الاوكراني المتمسكي بالمدينه والقوات
الروسيه التي تركت طريقا واحدا لقوتك من
اجل الانسحاب تزامنا مع صراعا بين القاده
الروس على كيفيه تسيير المعارك في محاور
العمليه العسكريه
تستعر المعارك في الشرق الاوكراني بعد
تعزيزات موسكو العسكريه لمحور دانيت الذي
شهد تقدما للقوات الروسيه في ظل انتقادات
مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر القتاليه لمسار المعارك
التي تديرها الدفاع في محاور عديده ذلك
بعد ان حقق مقاتلوا فاغنر نجاحا املموسا
شمال المقاطعه في مدينه
مجموعه اخرى من المقاتلين الاوكرانيين الى
ديارهم والذين قاتلوا بشجاعه ثم قتلوا
وزير الدفاع الروسي
ظهر فجاه في ميدان معارك دانيت كرد منه
على اتهامات
الذي قال ان الضباط الروس لا يعرفون شيئا
عن مجرى المعارك واوضاع الجنود مطالبا
بتحميلهم مسؤوليه الاخطاء
ننتظر منكم انجازات جديده وننتظر تحقيق
اهداف الخطط التي وضعناها لان جهدنا هام
جدا لوطننا رغم الارهاصات العديده التي
تشهدها العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الا ان
تنافسا كبيرا انطلق بين القاده الروس من
اجل تقديم انجازات ملموسه لسيد الكرل
انعكس نقصد ذخيره والسلاح عند القوات
الاوكرانيه خلال الاسابيع الماضيه على
مسار المعارك في العمليه العسكريه
ذلك ما ادى الى انخفاض وتيره القصف
الاوكراني على مناطق الانفصاليين في دمباس
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر
كشفت تقارير غربيه عن حاله من القلق
والفوضى في الداخل الروسيه عقب الهجمات
الاخيره على بعض المناطق الحدوديه التي
اصبحت مضطربه بشكل متزايد حيث تشهد عمليات
قصف متفرق واعمال تخريبيه منذ انطلاق
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه العام الماضي
تتزايد المخاوف في الداخل الروسي من تحول
البلاد الى ساحه اضافيه للحرب التي تدور
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه فالهجوم على منطقه
معارضون من الداخل ضد نظام بوتين يؤشر الى
تطور لافت خصوصا وانه ياتي بعد ايام من
هجمات بطائرات مسيره على مواقع داخل روسيا
تحطمت احداها قرب العاصمه موسكو استهداف
هذه المنطقه التي تخضع لتدابير امنيه
مكثفه كشف نقاط الضعف في الجيش الروسي
الذي بات امام موقف حرج يستدعي تغيير
خارطه المعارك واعلان الاحكام العرفيه في
المناطق الحدوديه بعد ان اثبت مقاتل
المعارض دينيس نيكيتن المنتمي لاقصى
اليمين الذي تبنى تنفيذ الهجوم قدرتهم على
اختراق بعض المناطق الحدوديه التي تخضع
لحراسه مشدده في العمق الروسي وفق مقال
نشرته صحيفه
للانتفاضه ضد سياسه بوتين وتوعد باستهداف
المزيد من الدفاعات الروسيه وهو ما خلف
حاله من القلق والفوضى
اوكرانيا التي اظهرت عده مرات قدرتها على
الضرب بعمق خلف خطوط العدو بهجمات بطائرات
بدون طيار وعمليات تخريب جريئه نفت دعمها
المباشره للتنظيم وصفه للاتهامات الروسيه
بالاستفزازيه بينما استغلت روسيا الحادثه
لتعزيز ادعائها بان الناتو يدير حربا
بالوكاله من خلال ارهابيين
وزعمت السلطات الروسيه ان الغاره اسفرت عن
مقتل مدنيين اثنين واصابه طفل
نشرت صحيفه الفرنسيه موجوده خلافات داخل
اوروبا بشان خطه المانيا لبناء درع
صاروخين اوروبي فقد اعلنت الصحيفه ان
باريس معترضه على بناء الدرع بمعدات
امريكيه واسرائيليه بينما ترغب اكثر من
خمسه عشره دوله اوروبيه بالانخراط في
الخطه الالمانيه
رئيس مجلس الروسيه قال ان نيه الشركه
الالمانيه مصنعه للدبابات فتح فرع لها في
كييف مؤشر على استمرار اوكرانيا بنهجها
فالتصيد واكد ان روسيا سترحب بافتتاح مصنع
ريان ميتال في اوكرانيا برشقه من صواريخ
كليبر
سنكر رئيس الوزراء العراقي السابق مصطفى
الكاظمي اوامر القبض على اعضاء حكومته
قائلا انها مرتبطه باحزاب وميول سياسيه
كما طلب القضاء العراقي بقيام بدوره
وبتحقيق دوليا شفاف مؤكدا على وقف التلاعب
والانتقام السياسي في العراق الكاظمي اكد
ان هذه التهم تكشف محاولات التستر
المستمره على المجرمين الفعليين حسب
تعبيره
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه اكد حسين الشيخ
امين سر اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه ان التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل
ما زال متوقفا لافتا الى ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه تتعاطى مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه
من الجانب السياسي وليس الامني احنا بعد
مجزره جنين
اتخذت القياده الفلسطينيه قرار واضح وصريح
بوقف التنسيق الامريكي وهو قرار سياسي
وليس قرار امني بمعنى اننا بدانا نفكر
جديا
بالانتقال من اللعب في مربع اسرائيل في
قصه انا العلاقه علاقه امنيه الى المربع
الاخر
العلاقه مع اسرائيل هي علاقه احتلال يحتل
الارض شعب اخر وبناء عليه يجب ان نعيد
توصيف العلاقه
مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المقابله الكامله مع امين سر لجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه حسين
الشيخ تتابعونها اليوم في تمام السابعه
مساء بتوقيت السعوديه
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر تعلن خط
اثنين من موظفها في مالي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الداخليه
التركيه سليمان سويلم ان عدد القتلى في
تركيا جرائد زلزال الهائل الذي ضرب تركيا
الشهر الماضي وصل الى 45 الفا وتسعمائه
وثمانيه وفي حديثه بمدينه انطاكيا التي
دمرتها الزلازل في جنوب البلاد ان اربعه
الاف ومئتين وسبعه وستين قتيلا في تركيا
هم من المواطنين السوريين
قال القائد الثاني لقوات الدعم السريع في
السودان عبد الرحيم انه يجب تسليم السلطه
للشعب وانهم لن يسمحوا بقتل المتظاهرين ما
يؤكد خلافا بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
في وقت اكدت فيه قوى الحريه والتغيير
موقفها من الاغتيال والقمع المتواصل الذي
ترى انه قد ينسف العمليه السياسيه الجاريه
الان في البلاد
سلم السلطه للشعب بدون لف ولا دوران
رسائل تتوالى من قاده الدعم السريع في
بريد السلطه العسكريه القائمه تؤكد ان
الخلافات لم تهدا او تحل هذه المره جاءت
التلميحات المبطنه من القائد الثاني لقوات
الدعم السريع عبد الرحيم والسبب هو قتل
المتظاهرين الرجل الذي يعتبر احد قاده
المنظومه الامنيه وجه انتقادا وكذلك
تهديدا بانهم لن يسمحوا باعتقال السياسيين
مره اخرى من الليله
وصاعدا بعد موت الشهيد ربنا يرحمه لن نسمح
باي قد الشباب المتظاهرين ولن نسمح باي
اعتقال للسياسيين
تحالف الحريه والتغيير والقوى الموقعه على
الاتفاق الايطالي ينظرون بقلق ويستشعرون
خطر الاتهامات المتبادله بين الجيش والدعم
السريع لكن في ذات الوقت يبدو ان تصريحات
الدعم السريع هي الاقرب لموقفهم السياسي
ومع ذلك يظل السؤال الاهم والمطروح من
قبلهم عن جدول عمليه السياسيه الحاليه
الذي نراه الان هو تطور مهم نحن نرحب به
هنالك تحديات تواجه العمليه السياسيه من
ضمنها
الممارسات التي حدثت في الايام الماضيه ضد
المتظاهرين هذه تعوق العمليه السياسيه
وهذه تناقض روح الاتفاق الايطالي وبالتالي
هذه التحديات يعني تختبر صدق وجديه كل
الاطراف الموقعه لاتفاق الاطار على راسها
الجانب العسكري يرى العسكر والمدنيون ان
تسليم السلطه للشعب هو افضل الحلول لهذه
الازمه لكن كيف يتم ذلك مع تباين واضح
بينهما طالما هو نطق بكلمه بدون لف او
دوران انا اعتقد انها هي مفتاح الحل لكل
المشاكل هو تسليم السلطه للشعب بدون لف او
دوران بدون لف او دوران يعني تسليمها
بصوره فوريه بدلا من انتظار عمليه سياسيه
تلكعت كثيرا وتاخرت كثيرا خلال الفتره
والشهور الماضيه ما ان تهدئ التصريحات
والرد عليها بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
حتى تعود مره اخرى لتفتح باب التساؤلات
على مصراعيه ما يجعل الوضع السياسي
السودانيه على صفيح ساخن سالم الهاشمي
العربيه الخرطوم
اكد رئيس مجلس النواب الليبيه عقيله صالح
خلال لقاء مع هيئه مشايخ ليبيا واعضائها
في برغا برقه وطرابلس وفزان ان التعديل
الدستوري الثالث عشر يلبي رغبه الشعب في
اجراء الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
داعيا الى اجراءها في وقت متزامن المركز
الاعلامي للرئيس البرلمان قال في بيان ان
صالح دعا الحاضرين الى ضروره توحيد الصفوف
والمشاركه في حل الازمه ودعم الحوار
الليبي الخالص كما دعا صالح الى رفض
التدخل الخارجي في شؤون ليبيا والعمل على
تحقيق التوزيع العادي للثروه والمطالبه
بتفعيل الدبلوماسيه الشعبيه لايصال صوتهم
للمجتمع الدولي وبحسب المتحدث باسم رئيس
البرلمان اكد الحاضرون من هيئه المشايخ
على ضروره وجود سلطه تنفيذيه واحده تفرض
سيطرتها على كامل ليبيا لتهيئه الاجواء
للانتخابات واعتبار وحده وسياده ليبيا خطا
احمر لا يمكن المساس به
نظم الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل تجمع عنه
عماليا ومسيره احتجاجيه في شوارع العاصمه
التونسيه احتجاجا على ما وصفه بالتضييق
على الحريات النقابيه وشيطانه الاتحاد
ورفضه للسياسات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
التي تتبعها الحكومه
من امام بقريه احادي الشغل ببطحاء محمد
علي وسط العاصمه لم يفوت نور الدين
الطبوبي الفرصه لدعوه السلطات التونسيه
للتراجع عما سماه تضيقا على العمل النقابي
وشيطنه اتحاد الشغل التبوب استغل الاجتماع
العامه والمسيره العماليه لتاكيد رفضه
شروط صندوق النقد الدولي والاصلاحات التي
تنوي الحكومه المواصلات فيها
المنظمه على قناعتنا وما بدانا التي تاسست
عليها المنظمه فالسياده الوطنيه وفي
استقلاليه القرار الوطني
وفي طرف المقابل يؤكد الرئيس قيس سعيد انه
لا مجال للرجوع الى الوراء وان المحاسبه
مطلب شعبيه كما انه لا مجال لاستغلال
العمل النقابي لدعوه اجانب للاحتجاج في
تونس
هناك من يريد ان يبدو بعض الاشخاص الاجانب
للتظاهر في تونس
وهذا امر غير مقبولا على اي مقياس من
المقاييس
عوده الاتحاد للاحتجاج في الشارع والتلويح
بالاضرابات عده تصعيدا جديدا من قبله ضد
السلطات ومؤشرا على توتر العلاقه بين
طرفين الخطاب اليومي الذي قفز به الامين
العام الاتحاد مره اخرى باتجاه التصعيد
السياسي هو خطاب يتلاقى كما يعني يعلم
الجميع بل في التحالف الطبيعي
والاستراتيجي ما بين الامين العام نور
الدين الطبوبي ورئيس حركه النهضه الغنوشي
ويستعد الاتحاد للاعلان الاسبوع المقبل عن
مبادرته لانقاذ البلاد كما يقول رفقه
منظمات اخرى قبل عرضها على الرئيس سعيد
الى شارع
ما ينزل
تحت الحريات
والعمل تطورات يؤكد المتابعون انها ستكون
محدده في رسم ملامح العلاقه بين النقابات
وسلطه مستقبلا وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
اعلنت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر عن
تعرض اثنين من موظفيها للخط في امس في
شمال مالي على الطريق بين مدينتي غا وكيدا
واكدت اللجنه انها موجوده في ماله منذ 32
عاما وانها منظمه محايده ومستقله وغير
منحازه طالبه عدم القيام بتكهنات بشان هذا
الحادث حتى لا يتعرقل حله
دعت وزاره خارجيه كوريا الشماليه الامم
المتحده الى المطالبه بوقف فوريه
للتدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بين الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه وقالت الخارجيه
في بيان ان هذه التدريبات مشتركه المعلن
اجراءها هذا الشهر تصعد من التوتر الذي
ينظر بالخروج عن نطاق السيطره والقت كوريا
الشماليه باللوم في وقت سابق على الولايات
المتحده في مواصفته بانهيار الانظمه
الدوليه للحد من التسلح فقالت ان اسلحه
بيونج النوويه هي رد عادل لضمان توازن
القوى في المنطقه
بعد ان حرمنا من حقوق التعليم والعمل
النساء في افغانستان يعانينا للحصول على
حقوق اصيله لفتها السياسه المتشدده
الجديده الغتها وتتخذها حركه طالبان امام
النساء والمتزوجات والمطلقات مزيد من
التفاصيل في التقرير التالي
النساء في افغانستان حرمان من حقوق اصيله
نتاجها سياسه متشدده تتخذ حركه طالبان
فبعد ان حرمنا من حقوق التعليم والعمل
وارتياد صلاه الرياضه والحدائق والمنتزهات
وغيرها من الحقوق هاهن يواجهن مصيرا جديدا
خلقته افكار الحركه لا تابى بانصاف الحلول
المصير الجديد بات التكمن تفاصيله في
النساء المطلقات اللواتي يواجهن مصير
الخلود الى السجن والعقاب والاسباب رؤيه
ترى بها حركه طالبان بانه لاحق للمراه
الافغانيه بان تطالب بخلع زوجها والحصول
على الطلاق بامر من المحكمه في حال اثبتت
ان زوجها يقوم بتعنيفها او يتعاطى
المخدرات وهو النهج الذي كانت الحكومه
الافغانيه السابقه ترى به حقا اصيله
ومن ارض افغانستان يرى قضاه ومحامون
سابقون ان الاف النساء الافغانيات اللواتي
حصلنا على الطلاق دون موافقه الزوج يتعرضن
الان للتهديد والخطر في ظل حكم طالبان
ويواجهن احتمال الاتهام بالزنا لللواتي
تزوجنا مره اخرى تزايد وتيره قمع النساء
في افغانستان لم تقف عند هذا الحد فحركه
طالبان اغلقت مجموعات الاغاثه المحليه
التي كانت توفر الماوى والاستشارات للنساء
اللواتي يسعين للهروب من العلاقات الاسريه
السيئه
اعلنت الصين رفعه ميزانيتها العسكريه
بنسبه
7.2% لهذا العام في تسارع طفيف مقارنه مع
العام الماضي وجرى الاعلان عن هذا المعدل
وهو اعلى مما كان عليه عام 2022 في تقرير
لوزاره الماليه وتخطط بيكين لانفاق نحو
225 مليار دولار على دفاعها اي اقل بثلاث
مرات من ميزانيه واشنطن
هذا وقال رئيس مجلس الدوله الصيني خلال
افتتاح الاجتماع السنوي للبرلمان قال انه
يتعين على القوات المسلحه تكثيف التدريب
العسكري والاستعداد في جميع المجالات
وتطوير توجيه استراتيجي عسكري جديد وتكريس
قدر اكبر من الطاقه للتدريب في ظل ظروف
القتال وبدل جهودا منسقه بشكل جيد لتعزيز
العمل العسكري في جميع الاتجاهات
والمجالات
غيب الموت صباح اليوم الفنانه والمطربه
المصريه شريفه فاضل عن عمر ناهزه 85 عاما
بعد صراع مع المرض شريف فاضل اشتهرت
باغنيتها ام البطل التي غنتها بعد وفاه
ابنها سيد السيد بدير خلال حرب اكتوبر من
العام 1973
الى العناوين
ايران تتراجع وتسمح باستئناف التحقيق
بانشطتها النوويه وجروسي يؤكد اعاده
كاميرات المراقبه
روسيا تؤكد تعزيز التعاون العسكري مع
الصين ردا على تعزيزات الناتو في اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ
وكوريا الشماليه تطالب بوقف فوري
للتدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بين امريكا
وكوريا الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]